so today's topic Stephen Crowder if you
aren't aware Stephen Crowder's uh
right-wing commentator very popular
right now I think he's shifted to rumble
uh not much on YouTube as much uh and
he's been going through a divorce now
why should you care honestly you
probably shouldn't
um but Stephen router
he's been involved in a few different
situations recently now the divorce
comes after his wife alleges that he was
emotionally abusive in the relationship
itself there's a ring video as well as
an article that's came out from a sub
stack by yashar uh and there's also a
video from Stephen Crowder talking about
the new Force so first let's play the
Stephen Crowder video on the
conservatives sphere there was a lot
more of the focus being on crowder
versus Candice Owens that's because on
his podcast Crowder talks about how he's
been dealing with a divorce since 2021
saying he kept it private by people in
positions of power knew that this was
happening with him alluding to extortion
and threats about exposing that
information then playing a clip of
Candace Owens speaking about him there
she seems to question his Christianity
says that he's going through a lot says
we should pray for him and then you had
Owen's uploading a video titled Stephen
Crowder accused me of extortion saying
he always pains himself as the victim
saying no one's threatened him or made
demands behind closed doors saying
Crowder sent her a flirty Instagram DM
on midterm election night that she
didn't respond to saying after that he
began his attacks on The Daily wire and
concluding that the divorce is why he's
spiraling and acting a rat she then
sends Crowder a cease and desist
demanding a full retraction and then
invites Crowder's wife on her show so
with all of that I gotta say I don't
care about that part let him fight it
out that's messy with your political
opponent is basically saying like yo
wife come come come come throw some dirt
on Crowder's day yo that's foul but for
me what was the most interesting was the
Insight that it gave on what he and
people like him think should be legal or
not with Crowder very much seemingly not
a fan of the law my then wife decided
that she didn't want to be married
anymore
and in the state of Texas that is
completely permitted and I still believe
that children need a mom and a dad and
that divorce is horrible
but in today's legal system
my beliefs don't matter
in Texas divorces permitted when one
party wants it
period and she wanted something else for
her life
that's not my choice
she simply wanted out and the law says
that that's how it works that's no one's
fault but my own
in that I picked wrong so that's how he
feels about it he describes it he claims
that Candice always is extorting him
hasn't provided any proof kind of a
crazy allegation but whatever so let's
play the video of how Steve and Crowder
treats his wife
I know you hate the dude but God damn
gradual boundary
because if you refuse to do to do right
for things then I will go pick up the
groceries and there is no groceries
wood pellets my grill
I know it's not a reasonable effect
how about you first
how do you respect
I'm a man
mind you this lady is pregnant like not
little pregnant that belly bigger than a
[__] eight months pregnant
and you're not gonna let her take the
car you wanna let her take the Uber
because apparently they only have one
car and
yeah that's why I'd like to sing the
Uber thing
what no no no what's your point I don't
understand why they wouldn't have
multiple cars that's weird
maybe the car the car is being repaired
they sold them you don't have to have
two cars it doesn't matter because it's
during the quarantine so basically he's
saying like if you take it then I can't
leave and she's not expensifying when
she's gonna come back I'm trying to
unless everybody's [__] on them
then your unpregnant ass take the Uber
Dan
okay if she's good enough take a uber
because she pregnant you're unpregnant
mainly [__] right wing ass well bro
why did you say right wing but because
usually they're they're more about you
know gender roles and stuff like that
I'm the man I'm the one so if you're the
man you're the one that's stronger she's
gonna run the errands you gonna take
your manly hands with the Uber okay all
right yay
you mean okay okay pregnant okay
okay oh oh you oh you are a special kind
of soft
so you're not taking [__] yeah
you are not then I will ask someone
would you let me dance
give him an Uber
okay Stephen I can't
I guess someone to pick me up
didn't an Uber I just let somebody go
pick her up she she made a compromise I
don't even understand what's going on
right now but again this is the weird
thing we're seeing a conversation three
minutes long in the middle of something
I don't I don't know what the problem is
I don't know where the problem starts
but I'm already like
off on Stephen Crowder so many people
who are different who are not connected
to him or not connected to each other
have alleged that he's very controlling
he has a bad temper he's very like and
you know the stuff that he handled with
the daily wire was really shady in my
opinion so this is like falling in line
with what a lot of people say about him
I would give him a normal person the
benefit of the doubt because he's got
such a bad rap online this [__] look
kind of crazy even with a bad rep
being so [__] adamant about the
[__] car and you're letting her take
a uber it's like who raised you yeah but
yeah you you don't know the world of
context that exists in a long marriage
like I understand what you're saying
maybe she'd not been helpful at all
throughout the whole marriage even if
she is she's taking an Uber to go to do
the groceries
that that's her action if she hasn't if
she hasn't been helpful and now she's
taking the call it sounds like she's
gonna leave and she's not specified when
she's coming back which is might be the
issue at hand here I can understand so
again that's why I don't know but to me
what indicts him is the prior exactly
[Music]
listen to
listen to me I can't go to my parents I
can't call my friends I can't go I can't
be boom you're gonna take the car and
leave me here Hillary just think of how
boxing you've made me what do you need
me to pick up I'll get it I'll be back
when I'm back no that doesn't work
either you'll be back when you're back
but it doesn't work either
I I understand the difference between
one life being sent to the setting and
you're going to put it back home
[Music]
the only way out of it is done it's the
only way out of it I will say it is a
really bad idea to be highly stressing
your wife while she's this pregnant it's
bad for the baby and it's bad for your
wife take a Uber it doesn't seem like
this is about the car no it's not it's
not about the car clearly not
control
that's what it is that's what I see
plenty of studies back that up like
stress actually makes adverse pregnancy
outcomes by disrupting uh blood flow
high blood pressure uh having a low
birth weight infant uh pre-term birth
and so you have to be mindful when
someone is that pregnant is not a good
idea to be in these kinds of situations
continuously and for what she described
their marriage has been tenuous like
this for a long time
he's sick
watch it
[__] watch it
okay
I need some space
okay I love you
I love you very much
I don't love it that's the big brother
I've never received love from you and
the fact is when I don't look I need to
do a b c and d you just put out a video
now but I love you more than life itself
okay
put on some gloves now but I love you
more than myself that's not fair that's
not fair and it's disingenuate Hillary
you're right right now become someone
down worthy of a life worth no matter
the life
Hillary Hillary come on now I'm not
gonna engage I'm not gonna engage
anymore I'm gonna go I'll get texting
what you need I'll get you the TV
bye
I love you
I'm committed to you
nice
enough to do those things you're not
committed to anything you're not
committed to anything
you just said I love you I'm committed I
walk the dogs put on some drugs
okay so it sounds like he's demanding
from his eighth month pregnant wife to
do some labor to prove that she's
committed because he feels like she just
says stuff and doesn't do it with
actions uh
apparently she didn't want to walk the
dogs because apparently to some degree
it could be poisons towards the child
and he really wanted her to so those are
some of the many problems that they have
together
I'm good
yes
are you committed enough to get the
medication
I don't know how true this last
statement is because I didn't hear it
him saying I will [__] you up that's
obviously something you should never say
to your partner
I don't think there's any context that
makes that acceptable but again you
don't hear it on camera so I can't say
too much I will read a little bit a
couple excerpts from the article itself
they say that she's been spending years
hiding her husband's mental
um and emotional abuse from her family
and that he lied about the circumstances
around their divorce and that he wasn't
present for the birth of their children
nobody's saying that anyone was beaten
in this marriage or that there was
infidelity and in audio files and text
messages that Yeshua received Stephen
Crowder admits to some of his faults
which include a volcanic temper
repeatedly and at times regretically
regretfully
apparently this is one thing I thought
was really interesting Crowder in the
video you guys saw earlier complains
about the no fault divorce things
in June 2021 Stephen left their home to
pursue elective surgery Hillier urged
him to get help he needed to address his
behavior with the hope that their
marriage could be saved now they could
possibly live together as a family
instead Steven refused to do so and
choose to not be his wife during the
birth of their twin children
uh
Harry was unaware that Stephen Crowder
had hired a divorce attorney and asked
his assistant to cut Hillary off
financially there's significant
documentation substantiating these facts
and I still believe that children need a
mom and a dad and that divorce is
horrible
but in today's legal system
my beliefs don't matter
in Texas divorces permitted him going
out talk about she wants a divorce but
he's been talking to a divorce lawyer
and then he'd been cutting her off
financially those kind of circumstances
make things a little bit sus that's
weird
especially when you say something
different publicly what you claims yes
you wanted this one because I got money
I got money but you went when she didn't
even know about it about a divorce yeah
you felt it
what are your thoughts on this
well it's not something that we should
care about because that that's that's
really that's from the personal point
what's happening when his wife actually
changes nothing in my perception of that
guy yeah it just more so confirms a lot
of like a donkey yeah I mean so I'm not
I'm not big on I'm not bad especially
when you you don't expose your wife like
that you don't put your wife out there
like that you know I mean you don't put
your you know so I'm not gonna I'm not
it's crazy yeah I want to do that I'm
like yo what the [__] is wrong with you
but then again it really doesn't change
much no so I would say this confirms a
lot of what I already suspected about
him from everything I've heard from
everyone else including people I know
personally who've worked for him uh I'll
say that also
is interesting to hear someone complain
about the fact that one party can choose
to make a divorce happen I understand
people don't want divorces to be taken
lightly but the idea that you would need
the consent of the other person in order
to set up a divorce no especially not
seeing that kind of conversation and
what I saw unfold if that is more of the
norm and that Dynamic that was presented
in the video is true for the entirety of
the marriage or most of it then I would
want a scenario where the person who's
having to suffer that at eight months
pregnant can file for a divorce if need
be I do think you know there should be
some measure of couples counseling or
things like that that people have to go
through for an extended period before
that's possible but but it shouldn't be
mandatory because not everyone's
circumstance are the same and the last
thing I would want is for someone to be
stuck in a marriage with somebody who
beats them who treats them terribly
every single dare whatever the [__] it
is like I know it's just weird hearing
you say that especially after finding
out that this man was talking to a
divorce lawyer like what the [__] are
you talking about and that's what makes
it seem like he's just doing a bunch of
PR [__] online for his right wing
Rift is because he's just out here
Pandora like oh my God I'm such a true
good Christian I don't even believe in
divorce in my wife you know in this
non-christ-like manner is able to
divorce me without like it's like bro
shut the [__] up if you were really
talking to the divorce lawyer man off
yourself get the [__] up out of here
that is the most disingenuous PR stunt
to control a narrative publicly and
that's what Stephen does a lot you saw
it when he recorded the phone call with
his then friend or so-called friend
where he recorded their call and put
that [__] out to the public to like
frame him a certain type of way after
editing out many parts
um yeah I mean if you look at the
comments there's a bunch of there's a
bunch of right winners I like
he's weird yeah and also weirdo
apparently likes cross-dressing all this
other stuff I don't really care but him
just accusing people of extorting him
like show the proof
show the proof
you guys love facts and evidence
show the facts and evidence yeah but as
far as what I saw in that video yeah
that [__] don't look good but I'll
Reserve judgment because there may be
more contacts that could make me change
my mind but in a vacuum that [__] don't
look nice and with the context of who
this man is that [__] don't look nice
and so that's probably My overall take
yeah anything else no no
you're not gonna send your wife pregnant
to to get an Uber
I got multiple cars
and you don't even make
I don't make her out of money how this
man got one more I don't make there's no
reason you should have three yeah I mean
maybe you have different beliefs you
know your environmental I'm gay I'm free
bro I'm giving the benefit of the doubts
three but in the summer I got a way out
it doesn't matter I'm not touching I
don't I remember to know that they're
not whatever